hi
good evening everyone and good evening
and welcome to this central area
planning committee
on wednesday the 2nd of june 2021
my name is councillor michael edwards
and i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols
agreed that canceled on the 29th of
april 2021
in the interests of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
when when invited to speak please remove
your mask
put on your visor turn on your
microphone and speak clearly
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
and ensure your microphones may not
remain off when not speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers
regarding the different levels within
the chamber and advise that the fire
exit is the door behind this top
table item two apologies for absence
are there any we've received everybody
thank you item three minutes of the last
meeting the 21st of april 2021
these are on page seven to ten
can i uh move that uh these are true and
accurate record or do you want to go
page by page
so do you agree by kind of a second or
first please
thank you countless thoughts um so agree
by ascent
thank you
item for declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
are there any just cancerous stupid
council morris thank you mr chairman um
just so i've got a pecuniary entry
non-pecuniary interest sorry in item
seven and eight
uh pot drive fitness and squash club i'm
a member of
don't get down there half as much as i
should but um i'm a member of and have
been for a while
and uh number eight is um
mr salisbury who is a um
haybush parish councillor and a friend
although
he is not on my christmas card list and
we've never exchanged bodily fluids
thank you thank you morris
i'm totally sorry i'm so excited about
receiving lbp
um yes a non-pecuniary interest in item
eight as i'm acquainted with the
uh the applicant and the non-pecuniary
sorry a non-pecuniary interest in item
eight i'm
as i'm acquainted with the applicant and
a non-pecuniary interest in item eight
again as i'm in uh equated with the
applicant thank you
thank you um council again
yeah thank you chairman uh non-pecuniary
all of these number five
uh as i live on the road and i've spoken
with the river bailiff regarding
moorings in
in the past for a vessel i once owned
number six shakespeare drive i've
corresponded with residents about
bus routes and have a relative who lives
on the street
number seven park drive i'm an ex-member
of the club and my late mother used to
work there
number eight and i've spoken on this
agenda item
as an independent member of the public
at malden town council and i reserve the
right under localism act
to hold a different view as a district
councillor thank you chair thank you
councillor council uh
thoughts
thank you mr chair um the same as
counselor lagan really it's a
non-pecuniary on all of them
i know item five i know the applicant
on item six i'm a world member and we've
had
um consultation with some of the people
in the world
item seven as at the moment i'm still a
member but that runs out this month
and item a as i know the applicant
thank you uh councillor man
uh yes thank you chair um items
uh five seven and eight uh because i'm
acquainted
with the applicant's non-pecuniary
interest thank you thank you councillor
herd
and thank you chairman items five and
eight non-pecuniary as i know both
applicants
thank you thanks for seance did you have
your hand up
no no okay i also would like to declare
non-betweener interest and i can eight
as i'm also acquainted
to mr swordsby as your sahabi paris
council
item five um 21 stroke zero zero two
three zero where we move to item five
this is now
found on page eleven to eighteen and can
i ask miss king to please
represent her report thank you
thank you chairman
planned permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing
single story lean to extension and the
erection of a single story rear
extension
a rear-facing dormer roof lights and
alterations to internal layout
this is the location plan showing the
proposed site outlined in red
this is the proposed block plan
this is the existing ground floor plan
the existing first floor
the plan ground floor plan showing the
extension to the rear
the proposed first floor plan showing
the changes to the layout of the rooms
and the proposed second floor plan
showing where the
position of the dormer and the roof
lights
these existing elevations
and these are proposed elevations
these are the photographs of the site
showing the
dwelling from the front and the rear and
the neighboring dwellings
either side
the application is recommended for
approval
thank you chairman thank you um
members now i now open the debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you have on this report
please cancel morris thank you mr
chairman um
i've looked at this question quite
extensively i believe that
the officers got this one right and um i
propose that we
approve this thank you thank you do you
have a second to do that
one second thank you
well i was just about seconded actually
but i i know the property as well
uh unfortunately it's become quite run
down
in recent years and i think the proposal
is fine it's in keeping it's not going
to change the look of the frontage
and like councillor morris i agree with
the
officer's recommendation so i think we
should
well personally i'd like to support it
thank you councilman
any others no
well we have a proposal on the table
then so the proposal is to approve this
so to have show hands or a sent or
recorded that's it oh that's it then
that's passed
thank you thank you mr king can i ask
you to leave the meeting with the door
thank you very much
so
okay
okay remember the item
agenda item 6 one zero zero two three
eight four shakespeare drive
uh these can be found on page 19 to 24.
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application has been
circulated prior to the meeting
and can i ask um is pleased to represent
your report
thank you chairman
uh the application is for a single story
exception to the rear of the existing
dwelling the development would also
include a number of alterations to an
existing single story rear
addition including raising the roof to
bring it in line with the height
of the proposed extension and the
provisions of a roof light
this is the application site
here is a single story extension
existing sorry
here is the proposed extension
the existing elevations the proposed
elevations
existing floor plans
the proposed floor plans
photos taken from the rear
garden uh
additional photos from the area garden
and the front of the property and the
street scene
uh the recommendation for this
application is um
is that for approval thank you chairman
thank you
members that i know open the debate
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you have on this report
amazing uh yeah thank you mr chairman um
my only question is um it says it's a
member calling but
it doesn't really give us any idea as to
why can can you just enliven me on that
please
thank you chairman that's in cloud
and contained on the members update
thank you cancer still caught it in
cancer news come tomorrow
i can't see any objections is there was
there any objections maybe i've missed
the update
do you want to update on that
i'm not objections but the update
but the update was due to the bulk and
scale of the development
um the reason for calling in fact cancer
thoughts perhaps would you like to
um thank you mr chair um
the reason for calling this in is that
um i felt that it was detrimental to the
health and well-being of the occupant of
the annex through the bulk and scale
of the design the window that you saw
in the back of the property that is the
kitchen window will go
and they are going to raise the roof of
the kitchen can you go to that slide for
us jade
so hit this one no back again
yes so i think there's another one
that's better
so when you look at that there is a
kitchen window the kitchen window will
disappear
they are going to raise the roof of the
kitchen and put in a
velux window which i'm not sure by
looking at the plans where that deluxe
window is
opening which then would mean that the
occupant had no ventilation in the
kitchen
and i do believe that it shows that the
there will be a narrow alleyway between
the bedroom
door which leads out to the immunity
space
thank you thanks for watching back on
that
thank you councillor stilts um uh that
helps me
a little bit um i'm minded to
approve the officer's recommendation
with this one because
uh i feel that you know it's it's got
more pluses than minuses
so uh i would propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation
thank you councilman
uh yeah thank you um uh councillor
stilts mentioned something about
developed window and there being no
ventilation
is this an opening window or is this a
fixed window
can we answer advice chairman i can pick
this up um
part submission doesn't include that
level of information um
the a kitchen window isn't habitable
accommodation in planning terms there
wouldn't
be a standard of living based
required in relation to that there is
building regulations requirements in
relation to
ventilation but that isn't a planning
matter thank you chairman
thanks for swinging yes
can i just clarify how this um relates
to the neighbor
um there's a semi detached property
isn't it
um i'm not quite clear whether it does
affect the neighbors
neighbouring property or not
it shouldn't affect the neighbouring
property um from
from the top photo it will come out to
their extension i believe so it
shouldn't have any
overshadowing or dominance on the
neighboring property thank you
i can't show it yeah i think it's yeah
i'm
sort of minded to sort of agree with
what council still says about the bulk
and the scale of the thing
that area of the street is a very well
balanced street scene
and the building at the back and the
word should causes me a little bit of
concern as it shouldn't
interfere with the light or overshadow
but doesn't mean that it
wouldn't so i have a have some concerns
based on on the size of it and also with
the
the potential for the light although as
mr lee's just said it's not a planning
term
but i would like to read you that
concern okay thank you councilman
yeah thank you mr chairman sorry um can
we have another look at the
um the out the base plan to see where
um the extension comes to in relation
there was one that was in relation to
the
the neighbor yeah thank you
so if i've got if i've understood the
plan correctly the
the line on the left hand side
is is is not going it's not going beyond
is that right
yeah yeah so it's it's the same yeah
okay thank you for you chairman can i
just make a certain comment in relation
to the point just
made about um is his comment
it's very rare for planners to put down
category there will be no
zero harm because it's a perspective
thing and one person may consider that
there is harm
when another one won't but what we talk
about is the level of harm that wants to
reason future that's why we'll say we
consider there won't be any harm but we
won't say definitively because it's to a
certain sense a subjective thing
but when assessing an application we
need to look at whether it's to such a
degree as to warrant a reason for
refusal
i've just noted a few times over
committees points of that have been
sort of raised i just wanted to clarify
that point that's why our reports say
that and why officers
answer questions in the way they do
because at the end of the day it's
yourselves as the decision maker
to make those decisions but just because
we haven't said something categorically
doesn't mean we aren't confident there
won't be harm
in our professional opinion thank you
chairman thank you
well we're councillor heard um thank you
chairman
um yes i mean i've looked at uh i've
looked at the plans there i
i can't really see any real problem with
it i think that it is
it's a single story rear extension
there's going to be lighting through the
roof
i personally don't have a don't have a
problem with it and
if it's been proposed to be uh agreed
i'm happy to second that thank you
councillor
um okay so
we'll put these two take the road from
then and the first
because yours wasn't a proposal was it
you were just a comment so we'll take
your proposal first so
that's right yeah yes so can i show a
handful
approval and
against so that's carried as well
thank you thank you
yes
okay i uh members okay item
seven twenty one stroke zero zero two
four nine park drive fitness and squash
club
uh these are found on pages 25 to 34.
and can i ask it's matthew please to
repent
report present your report thank you
thank you cameron everyone hear me
right so this is an application for a um
all-weather cover for existing panel
courts
um proposed new show court and an office
stroke change area at park drive
fitness and squash club so this is the
application site hatched in red
which currently forms part of the land
associated with the um the fitness club
so this is the application site in
closer detail so you've got the
and the arrow there is pointing to the
um what used to be the tennis court
there which is now
um the paddle court
um and that's how it is now with the
three paddle courts in the
in the corner there
so the proposal is to cover the three
paddle courts with um
a canopy and um
there's also a proposed show court um
to the south of that and the other arrow
is pointing to where the proposed office
and changing room would
would be located
so and this is the show court which is
basically the same
appearance and design and layout and
lighting as
the existing paddle corps with this this
one would be um
uncovered and then this is the proposed
roof for the
um the existing paddle cords
we've got elevations and floor plan of
the post offices
and just a small single story building
and then we've got some um photos there
of the existing paddle courts
parking area and on the bottom left
there the
existing fitness and squash club
buildings
thank you thank you
members i know open the debate and
invite you to port any questions or make
any comments you have
on the report please council morris
thank you mr chairman um
just like to say that uh as a council i
do believe that we should be supporting
all endeavors to increase the
community's fitness
and this one certainly doesn't seem to
have any drawbacks whatsoever
um it seems to be a
a winner any way you look at it and i
would like
to propose that we support the
application
thank you thank you councilman
um yes i agree again uh with councillor
morris on this and um
it's not that i would exercise uh
myself but um i think in this day and
age
outside exercise like this is excellent
for the community and so
i would support it i'd second the
proposal thank you catherine
yeah thank you chair i think that with
the history of this this premises
yeah when they first put in the open air
pool um that had to be covered up
so it could be used um as a 365 facility
um and when you go down there now and
watch the people on the paddle courts
it can only benefit the usage of
the courts and the facilities so like my
learning members
i'm fully prepared to support this
application thank you
council swain
and uh
three ten minutes open on all sides just
on post
and it was described earlier as a
glorified gazebo
but um or very big gazebo but that i
don't know whether that was that's not
technically correct but and to give you
an idea of
what it might look like obviously on a
bigger scale and so no it would just be
a roof described as
upvc roof it'll be off-white color i
think
and it would just be supported on posts
above the existing
courts
it
it's a permanent um
structure that will be over the courts
yeah so that
as one of them members said is that so
that they can
um continue to play even when it's
raining
okay council heard um thank you chairman
yes i would certainly approve this i
think it supports
a fit and healthy lifestyle i think it
supports the business and i think it
would support
and benefit those residents who use it
so i would certainly support it
thank you country stilts
thank you mr chairman and i think i was
the one that described it as a glorified
gazebo when i asked if it could be a red
green roof
um is there any way that they could put
sides on that in future
or is that a condition that we can put
in to say
that they couldn't
through chairman it might be arguable
that they
could put sides on um there'll be a
if you need to be taken whether it
materially altered the external
appearance of
the we were called a building or
structure um
but um for belt and braces then yes a
condition could be imposed to
ensure that if they did want to enclose
it then they would need to come back and
ask for a permission first
if members wish to impose that we can
something you would
yes uh mr chairman i would like to
impose that they don't put sights on it
um
and that we impose that condition um
if if they want to then enclose it at a
later date they'll have to come back and
ask for
planning permission again but i would
like to make sure it doesn't
happen your members agree on that
council heard
i'm not sure i do agree on that um term
to be honest i mean
we are asked to judge the application
that's in front of us
if they did want to put sides on it i
think it would materially
uh change it and i think that's
something that they would have to come
back but
even if they did i don't particularly
have a problem with it
so i'm not i'm not really sure i mean
i'm happy to go with if members want to
do that but
i wouldn't necessarily ask it to be a
condition
council mind thank you mr man sorry
am i being a little bit thick here
because what are the sides that they
might put on it as
i understand it we've got a uh a canvas
type roof
that's going to be going over and the
sides are enclosed by the
plexiglass or whatever it is that the
paddle tennis
um already has there but that is already
there so
what are we what sides are we talking
about please
i don't know can you clarify that sorry
uh um mr lee
three channel bit of clarity as matthew
said it's a bit of an argument about
whether or not would need development
whether it fall under the definition it
all to do with whether it materially
alters the structure and appearance
because this sort of development
wouldn't develop
wouldn't benefit from permitted
development so it would require consent
it would be a very belt and braces um
approach partly because actually if it
was anything
that would be even slightly problematic
for one of a better phrase i'd
consider we would consider it be
development and therefore would need
permission
um so if a condition would only limit a
very small amount of work
um whether or not so it's a bit hard
to answer council morris's point because
actually if it went to anything that you
know might spring to mind of
you know extensive work to this or doing
that it would likely fall into the remit
of development anyway and therefore
require permission
but it it it would only cover the gray
area to ensure that we didn't have
arguments in the future over things
rather than
explicitly protecting
something that would be harmful i would
suggest if remembers clarity
thank you do you members wish to add
this condition
council swain i would agree
put the conditioning rather than
have one certain position in future as
to whether planning commission
so the proposal is to approve but with a
condition
as laid out by mr lee correct
no through chairman for clarity that so
it would be a con
the conditions that are in the office's
report plus an additional condition
without moving the permit
development right or to removing the
rights for any formal development
that would be delegated to officers for
final wording through
consultation with yourself okay thank
you you all agree
can i have oh sorry cancer now well do
we not
needed to vote on the condition
do we need to vote on the addition of
the condition
yeah yeah do you chairman that's what
you'd be voting on
the application with all the conditions
we've said plus the additional condition
that's what we'll be voting on yeah
obviously if that was to fail then you
could move to the officer's
recommendation thank you
yeah just before we move to that um can
i just ask how rams plays into this as
well
um could i ask mr lee
it's not mentioned on any of the
applications that's all right
chairman rams relates to recreation
avoidance and mitigation and relates to
additional dwellings none of the
applications
okay thank you i just wanted to double
check thank you thank you
okay thank you um therefore um
can i have um we want to vote by sent
with
those conditions okay uh or do you want
to roll sorry
okay by us yes taking a vote on the
proposal
and with the additional position
with the condition yes
to approve sorry to approve with the
extra condition
silver all agreed okay thank you
so that's okay thank you
okay
are you ready okay thank you
um remember members item eight twenty
one stroke zero zero
three one four um the provenant park
and can i uh sorry please note that a
member's update in relation to this
application
has been circulated prior to the meeting
and can i ask
duncan pleased to present your report
thank you thank you chairman
planning permission is sought for the
conversion and renovation of an existing
public seating shelter
into a food serving kiosk please note
the members update which includes some
additional representations received for
the application
on the location plan submitted you can
see the site outlined in red which is
located
within promenade park which is also
within malden conservation area
promenade park is a non-designated local
heritage asset and lies within the
leisure quarter
as identified in the malden and
heybridge central area master
plan within the master plan the
application site lies
within an area which is identified as a
destination hub
for a combined visitor center and
specialist restaurant
on the plan i've identified the
locations of the existing kiosk and
other covered seating areas
which you can see by the arrows
this is the block plan for the
application
as you can see from the plan the shelter
is located on the southern side of a
pedestrian walkway
that runs east to west throughout the
park
and these are the existing plans for the
application
as you can see the current shelter has
an octagonal layout which is open on
four sides for seating and is
constructed using concrete breeze blocks
clay roof tiles and painted timber faces
the heritage and conservation specialist
has advised that although the structure
is broadly traditional in form and style
the breeze block walls are not
attractive
and the structure is architecturally
undistinguished
the shelter in its current form
therefore makes a neutral contribution
to the conservation area
these are the proposed plans for the
application
no changes are proposed to the overall
size of the structure
although four the four existing openings
would be infilled by new walls
painted timber cladding is proposed on
the elevations of the structure
which would appear similar to the
cladding used on the other structures
within the park
there would be a serving hatch to the
northern elevation of the building as
well as an access door
for staff to enter within the eastern
elevation
and the proposed hours of operation for
the kiosk would be from 8
30 a.m to 5 30 p.m
every day including bank holidays
this is a photo of towards the site and
you'll note that the arrow should be
further to the right there so apologies
for that
um but the application site is located
behind
or beyond the marine lake and i've also
noted here
the two covered seating areas along
the main promenade
this is another view back to the
application site over here
with a covered seating area in the
foreground
these are the four of the five existing
kiosks
in the area and this is the fifth
existing kiosk which is
on the same walkway as the application
site
this is the front of the existing
structure
this is the rear of the existing
structure
and this is the food truck that's
currently located
above the amphitheater in front of the
site
and this is a photograph of another
covered seating shelter in the area
so in line with the assessment carried
out within the committee report
the proposal is considered to be
acceptable subject to the conditions as
set out in section 8.
the council's heritage and conservation
specialist has raised no objections to
the proposal
and it is therefore recommended that
planning permission is granted for the
proposed development
thank you chairman thank you
we have one public participant for this
planning application
and in line with the public
participation scheme i now invite the
applicant mr salisbury
to read out his submission may i remind
you that
you allocated two minutes only for
public speaking in accordance with the
scheme
unfortunately we won't have it on the
screen because i've got it on my laptop
yeah okay
sure that he's gonna be broke anyway mr
salisbury would you like to
turn your microphone on and uh you have
two minutes
thank you right okay it's very brave i'm
just gonna go bullet points
so basically what the offer is is to
repurpose
an existing building that was due for
demolition
the removal by doing this it will remove
the antisocial behaviour which is
prevalent in the area the drug taking
the alcohol abuse is being used for a
toilet as well
on numerous occasions a lot and
by us going there we'll be raising the
bar of the park offer
with consistent open and closing time we
won't be cherry-picking our hours we'll
be doing
proper day the park encourages
healthy living and exercise in that
lifestyle
and what we'll be serving is healthy
foods salads etc there won't be no
burgers and fries
and what we'll be doing is also catering
for vegetarians vegans and people with
food intolerances via our click and
collect service
there is no cost to moulding district
council for this project
and we made an offer to build another
shelter as well
in any location the council won so we're
more than happy to take an undertaking
on that
whether it be this year next year or
whenever
probably the most important thing is
that we'll be creating four full-time
jobs
for local people we also support the
local supply chain
by mrs salisbury's which also supports
the local economy
and the final thing i would say is with
regard to the park run
that we have negotiated with the council
so with regards to the park run on the
saturdays
we will be closing our seating area on
the amphitheater until it is finished
thank you very much for your time thank
you mr swordsbury
members i now open the debate and invite
you to put any questions or make any
comments you have
on the report so starting with council
morris
thank you mr chairman um i have fond
memories
of this little hut i spent far too many
hours down there as a
school child probably being in school
when i shouldn't have been and um
i kissed the occasional girl in there as
well so it has got quite some nostalgic
memories for me
um problem is
it's just not what it was um it is in a
state of disrepair
um it does smell of wii um it does have
sick on it from time to time it has got
burn marks up the walls um it's not an
attractive place to be anymore
and as much as i look at this one a
little bit like i look at the mill beach
public house uh
brilliant old building loved it but well
past its day and it needs to be
replaced with something that can better
serve the community
and the residents i've eaten at mr
salisbury's and he does good food he
does quality food
and it's a um whilst i'm not moaning
about burgers and chips
it's it's a cut above what the other
places seem to offer and i found that
from personal experience
my my vision for the promenade would be
that we attract more older and
discerning
guests the promenade is getting busier i
use it
regularly on a weekly basis almost and
it is getting busier so we will need
better food places and this one seems to
tick all the boxes
this is a fantastic repurposing and
just a quick point i'd like to make that
if any other
um seating areas are made i'd like them
to be
ecological i'd like them to be
environmentally friendly i'd like
us to maybe plant some trees to make a
um a sheltered
bench part area because i don't believe
the promenade needs any more
buildings just repurposing the new ones
will do
absolutely fine so chair i'd like to
propose that we accept
um the officer's recommendation and uh
give this one approval thank you
sorry cancer man
[Music]
um well sticking to planning issues
uh i've got uh three things that i'd
like to raise please chair
first of all the extra representations
that we've received in the members
update
they're anonymous but i assume that
they're from members of the general
public
so i believe so i can double check for
you but they're not
from any society or anything
else the second thing is that i think
it's rather ironic that the conservation
officer is uh
being concerned about the breeze blocks
because presumably it was malden
district council that inserted the
breeze blocks in the first place
just an observation and the third point
is that malden town council seems to
have
suggested what appeared to me reading
this report
to be eminently sensible conditions
but those conditions don't seem to
appear in the
offices recommended conditions is that
proposed conditions is that
right please yeah i'm just double
checking the report for you but i know
that i have dealt with
um the recommended
conditions from the parish within the
body of the report
so it's just relating to the removal of
the food truck
and providing an alternative replacement
shelter are those the two points that
the parish
yeah um so through you chairman um
at paragraph
5.5.3
we have dealt with the recommendations
of the parish council
so the stationing of the food truck
to the front of the application site
doesn't actually benefit from planning
permission
it's obviously we would need an
application to assess where the planning
permission is actually
required for the food truck because i'm
not sure whether it's a temporary
structure in terms of we don't know how
many days of the year
is there or whether it leaves the site
at night so
because it doesn't actually benefit from
the grant of planning permission at the
moment we can't
condition that it's removed that would
just be subject to
either an enforcement case or discussion
outside of this application
we also consider because the loss of the
seating
shelter is considered acceptable when we
considered it against the policies
we wouldn't condition that there's an
another public seating shelter
constructed in its place because if we
felt that the
loss of the seating shelter was so
adverse we wouldn't be approving the
application
so that wasn't a reasonable condition
to add in this case but it is in 5.5.3
we have discussed that grateful uh
thank you chair and thank you for the
explanation thank you
thank you mr chairman can the officer
tell me exactly
how many eating establishments we got in
the park you only mentioned
four and there's at least two more
yes so um obviously i'm aware of
through your chairman um i'm aware of
the
application that was approved at
committee the other month
for the food kiosk at the golf course
um obviously there's five within that
central promenade park
area and there are some food outlets
further west of the site
but those are the ones that i'm aware of
thank you and can you tell me where the
nearest and how far it is
seating area covered seating area where
people can take
shelter from the rainies from the
application site yes
145 metres to the west and 110 meters to
the north
thank you uh councilman again
i'm sorry cancer
thank you councillors
first of all i have to say that i
support this application
wholeheartedly and the reason i support
it
is because i think that this
building as it is has no architectural
merit at all
um i think that i have
the people that i've seen using it are
those who are there for anti-social
reasons
so i certainly concur with what mr
salisbury is saying
um i i know that some people have
concerns about
um over subscription of shops
uh and establishments at the prom
but it's not a planning reason and
secondly what i do see is many many
queues
at these places so i think that actually
it is worth
another another establishment and if if
we have somebody who's willing to make
good of that
then i do applaud that um i would also
like to see the additional seating area
nearby and the reason i would like it
nearby is because if
if people are selling food there people
will want somewhere to sit
and eat it um close by so i think that
i'm not a supporter i'll be honest i'm
not a supporter of the truck
there but i am a supporter of this
application
and the reasons for it and therefore i
would propose that we
uh accept this recommendation to approve
thank you councillor councillor again
councilman
and for many of the reasons that have
both been pointed out by other
councillors
um so thank you thank you council
because council lag
thank you chair um based on the
the the information that's provided in
the offices report i've got some
concerns on this
and as councillor has rightfully said
the it's the council
that hasn't looked after the asset um
correctly when i was growing up it was a
wooden structure
well maintained and well used it's on an
area where
people with disabilities can easy access
it's
uh they still can yeah if it's removed
they can't um
they um they can okay um i didn't
interrupt you counsellor
can you please let me speak and then you
can come after me yeah well yeah
yeah because you're right on everything
um
sorry through the chair just stop please
thank you um
so we talk about the the access to the
shelter for people with disabilities or
non-disabilities
you're talking about a a shelter that is
is small and insignificant to a lot of
people but is used by a significantly
large amount of people
and i think because the application
notice was placed 31 meters away from
the site on a small
stake it was difficult for people to
look and to comment
um there's a couple of things actually
in the report that i think need to be
brought out as part of the debate purely
on planning um section 3.1.1 talks about
the prompt being identified as local
heritage park and a non-thirty
non-designated heritage
asset so it's an important area and the
shelter complements the area it just
needs
tidying up because we're a riverside
town
you ever sit in the shelter i did today
yesterday the day before and many many
times
it has a uniqueness in the fact that it
is not just rectangular
it has four sides which means when
you've got a nor easterly or an easterly
blowing
you can get some shelter and you can be
at ease with that
it's used by a lot of people not just
for antisocial behavior that's an
endemic problem in molten not just
within this shelter
3.1.2 talks about the four existing
kiosks 130 meters
and a hundred and a fifth only 65 meters
away and mr sarge was kind enough to
tell us about the offerings he's going
to do
doesn't mention the lakeside cafe the
barge tea rooms blackwater seafood
um it also has the pop-up vans there's a
hotdog van down there on on the bath
wall this morning
um how many do we need how many do we
really need and
whereabouts in the history of the prom
does it say that they're going to open
up for all insandry
i think the pop-ups are fantastic you
know that they're great but we don't
need any more fixed assets
um i agree that it won't flood but in
policy d35
and d3 section 3.28 it talks about
a conservation area to be an area of
architectural interest with a character
desirable to preserve
and protect when i contacted officers
and asked whether it was due for
demolishing it was denied that the
coffee
the shelter was due to be demolished it
needed renovating not demolishing
section 5.1.2 talks about the central
area master plan this is important
members
from a planning perspective because we
talk about project 15
talks about a visitor center and a
specialized restaurant there's no
visitor center
and there's no specialized restaurant so
we wait until that goes through
as part of the master plan
as good as good as a kiosk is it's not
specialized restaurant
5.1.3 reiterates what 5.1.2 says it
acknowledges the impact on the
established kiosks
so it acknowledges the fact that there's
going to be business taken away from
long-established businesses
so we have to be careful with that you
know
we talk about no harm in section 5.3.3
talks about no harm in a residential
amenity but in his conditioning
i can't register myself with that and
the ldp
page 55 6 and 3.8 it talks and this is
important about a loss of a building
and other element that makes a positive
contribution to set out in the relative
and conservation area
and the appraisal requires clear and
convincing justification
if it was tidied up it wouldn't need
clear convincing justification
there's a perfectly able run-down kiosk
area
in the kids play part that will benefit
from renovation that has very little
architectural merits
so the only it's the only one of its
kind on there people like nostalgia
can't esteem fair's a success you know
it is the only one of the kind it was
left in the park
for the people of oregon to use and to
say people don't use it well
well park run uses it excessively and
not just park run
a lot of other people use that so i'm
not in favor based on
the the following grounds i'd reject
this application
against policies policy e3 a loss of a
unique community asset
which is divided in described in our ldp
sector policy e53 a detrimental impact
an appearance of the area we'd lose the
shelter and and section
uh policy s5 section 7 to preserve the
historic character of the built
environment
it may seem like a little rundown
shelter to some people but it's part of
our history deserves preserving
and we could we could use other areas to
provide good facilities that mr soles we
could bring
and also in in closing members i'm very
disturbed about the way that this
has actually been handled with officers
and i believe it should go to overview
and scrutiny because it talks about in
our on our master plan and our ldp
about marketing for community assets
this hasn't been marketed
thank you members well we have a
proposal on the table
a proposal from council morris which has
been seconded by
rocky sorry cancer training
decision about demolishing it the second
is this is not an ordinary
planning application because um
overriding it must be the policies that
the
district council has towards the use of
promenade park
i don't like the way we've gone in a
piecemeal fashion
in allowing a kiosk here
another outlet there and
given that we've now got the one uh uh
permitted for the uh um the
what is it the mini golf area
i think we we have got enough um the
other thing the next thing is um
this would involve opening up a new area
for with catering um at the present time
it is um it's clear
it's an open area for people to enjoy um
and it includes next to it the pittank
area
um that is um
more could be made of it as a place
to sit um if you
position yourself there you'll see this
is the gives you the finest views
of the um of the estuary
um and that that's why we do need decent
accommodation for people to sit there um
the other another aspect of opening this
up as a new area with a kiosk
is i'm afraid as councillor heard has
alluded to it
it would then lead to seating outside
further expansion of that
in that area
so there is also the possibility
um that the
shelter and the in the play area
could be developed as um
a place for eating and also sitting
and with a good view down the um uh
the the estuary um i i
i think we we need to stop and have a
overall plan of what we want from
catering facilities in promenade park
um and and we need that really to be
able because as
i think uh councillor lagan has
referred indirectly um we've got
a lot of the same sort of kiosks and and
eateries
and what we need is a um so we say a
proper cafe
um permanent one where people can
can sit and that would be more likely to
um
to to invite a different segment of the
population
um including the older ones i think
perhaps that has been mentioned
so i would um i i would be against this
proposal
until we've got a clear eye firstly
because we don't don't want to lose that
area as
an open area for people to enjoy
we could make a lot more of the of the
existing structure um for sitting
and open up that area by simply removing
that hedge for insta
instance and it then would be between
open on at least three sides to public
view and less likely to
generate anti-social behavior um
so i i i think we i don't favor
this proposal at all
sorry uh mr lee dude chairman if it's
okay i'll just come back on a couple of
points raised by council swine and
councillor lagan
um i think it's very important members
that we remember this is a planning
application and it's a committee that
only has powers in relation to
planning termination plan applications a
lot of the points that have been raised
may well have merit but not necessarily
planning merit
you know issues such as how we approach
the delivery of services and facilities
within the
prom park as though we are owners it's
not a really debate for us here as the
planning committee
that's a debate for a different
committee and maybe discussion outside a
committee but
we have a planning application in front
of us to determine on its planning
merits
um i'll just try and go through a few
points um there's been a number of
points around potentially of
disappearance
how it's um could be tidied up and how
you know potential demolition things but
that hasn't been the formational basis
of the officer's recommendation you know
that's not been a
a particular point for consideration in
this
assessment of this application and i
would advise members
that how much value you give or don't
give to those points to assume
is a point in determination of this
application because it's not really
material situation
that there's been criticism of the
appearance and it's going to be
demolished and this retains it
um similar with in relation to the
independent behavior um
although there may be benefits to this a
wider
use of the park and also potentially
these could be overplayed or these could
be solved in other ways you know this i
wouldn't really give advise members to
give too much weight to in the
termination
application decorum of individuals isn't
really a planning matter
um we have to consider it in the big
pitch we have to ensure we can do things
that
stop it negative impacts because we
can't potentially control them in the
future
sorry i just that's where i was totally
um in relation to the central air master
plan the officer's report isn't trying
to
bring forward the argument that this is
any is the specialist restaurant or
visitor center this is an application
being assessed in its own merits
is not um being assessed as part of
the delivery of any specialist
restaurant and in relation to business
impacts that isn't material
consideration for determination of
application
um case law is clear on that
the point of a condition is to ensure
there won't be any impacts on neighbours
it's to
ensure in the long term that they are
mitigated you know
later at night in evening when there's
background ambient noise levels are low
they can carry very long distances so
the idea of having that condition is to
make sure that
um this kiosk is only open in hours when
there will be acceptable levels of
background noise to mitigate any harm
from
the site um and that's keep going on for
some reason
and that's something that is a standard
approach for
uh conditions um
my understanding is i think ms dungate
highlighted that that
the conservation area said officer said
that this structure was
uh had a neutral impact or something and
and i don't think officers disagree with
that and i don't think the assessment
doesn't
obviously individuals as members can
have a different opinion on that but
we have to be conscious of that would be
the advice from the conservation area
also in relation to community asset as
the officer's report
explains we don't consider that
this structure falls within that
definition and therefore
it doesn't need to be
marketed or anything like that because
that's not what we're considering our
policy relates to
and therefore it isn't a consideration
um i think that
covers most of the points just oh
the other thing would be obviously that
the if the air was to
be used for seating outside of it that
would require planning permission anyway
so that would be a subsequent
application
rather than just being automatically
allowed by the grant in this application
so i took quite a few points i think
i've covered i don't know if ms dungate
thinks i've missed anything she wants to
pick it up otherwise
thank you chairman thank you mr lee well
we
all right so who's first uh
i'm gonna ask him
the grounds for refusal could be
we want to retain it in its existing use
or we can say
that the proposed um proposal is not an
appropriate use of this
structure there's definite reasons for
free refusal
cancer hurt um
well thank you first of all
in its foreign state it is an unsavoury
place to sit
and the reason is is because of the type
of people who attracts
uh frankly there are only two views that
you can get from
one of them will be looking at hedge
but uh i think if there is a if
there is a concern about the loss of
anointing
then why can't we ask as a condition
with a similar structure
which is at the same and be constructed
but i would ask
lenders to the age 44 the conservation
officer
and that's why we employ a conservative
proposed conversion of the public
seating
or the conservation area as heritage
assets that's his professional opinion
yeah thank you chad i appreciate you
giving me the time to come back
and i won't be as long as it was in the
initial thing um no offense taking
council of her because i sat down
with myself and my seven-year-old dad to
shout out from the win so those type of
unsavory people
obviously you're referring to my good
self and other people
um and thank you uh mr lee for
for clarifying some of these areas as as
mr lee
you know the points i make are comments
on the officers report which is members
and ultimate decision makers uh with
your advice that that's
what we're here to do and basically as
as council sweden's quite rightfully
said there are grounds to reject this
current application
on on what councillor swain has said and
the points i've raised are from our own
local development plan
after careful consideration with the
house of commons library briefing paper
about following
your advice as professionals and as a
professional health and safety officer i
consider myself
to have most of the knowledge but not
everything um so policy e3
a lot of the unique community asset if
you were talking about
building we have something that we need
to retain and then we want to turn
around and build something
in the like for like of it to me it
doesn't make any sense and it goes
against the policy policies are there to
enact and also to support
the preservation of some of our
community assets and e3 is clear in that
e5 detrimental impact on the character
and preservative of the area
and and ss5 section 7 preserved the
historic couch and built environment
stop and have a look at that thing
previous
councils have allowed it to go to wrap
and ruin it would cost very little to
make it very very savory it would
probably help mr salisbury's business
because more people want to go and see
in it and also you know
we all do respect councillor heard yes
one view you do look at a shed
a hedge the other view as council swain
says you get the best view of the
history that there is in the town
and the other one to the side of it
looks across the lovely green grass
and the other one looks across the the
tennis courts
so that it's a unique piece of malden's
history and heritage which the policies
should protect
there are other buildings that should be
considered for a heritage for a center
with a restaurant facility with that but
this is not the one
i urge members not to support it council
mrs bill
yeah i'd like to think that uh 7.1
moldentown council's opinions are taken
into consideration
i mean it's basically in the town and i
think they've thought this through
and i think it's a good suggestion so
i'd like to see this
included any in any conditions
um right can't
sorry mr lee did jim just in relation to
councillor bill's point um
ms dungate did cover it when it was
asked by
council and numb but just for clarity
um malden town council
have requested that the food truck is
removed
firstly this application isn't a
personal permission
it is planning permission for the use of
a
structure for to find food um
we can make assumptions but planning
isn't based on assumptions about who
will be facilitating it who will be
within the kiosk but the structure
is or the planning mission sits on the
land so
firstly it's not personal commission so
it won't be appropriate
secondly there are question marks even
even if it's development they're of the
by using the
vehicle there because it comes and goes
so it it fails
a number of the tests under section 55
of what is development so it wouldn't
actually fall under the plan in control
and even if it does then that'd be a
breach of planning control which you
shouldn't use a condition
on a planning commission to resolve a
breach of planning control it should be
dealt with under the
planning enforcement power so for those
reasons we wouldn't recommend there's a
condition in relation to that
and in relation to the use of a
structure or requirements of a new
structure as the office report explains
it's firstly it's not considered to be
proportionate
it
if we were to use a condition it would
have to be a grampian condition which
would
require that the structure was in place
before the use of this kiosk
there is no confidence
in the lpa that the landowner wants to
have put in a new structure
that the landowner will facilitate a new
structure and that that would come
forward therefore be an unreasonable
condition to impose
if you were to look to it through a
unilateral undertaking on behalf of the
applicant where he
freely provides it firstly you may still
have a problem that the landowner
doesn't want to which then make
that legal agreement ultraviolet but on
top of that
it wouldn't be proportionate to require
a whole new structure in the placement
for one structure on the fact that we
are providing
an opportunity or there is an
opportunity to create
a new retail element for one of the
better phrase
it's not proportionate it wouldn't meet
the three tests for a section 106
so for those reasons i my professional
advice is that the
requirements of the town council don't
meet the test for being imposed thank
you chairman
thank you thanks tomorrow thank you mr
chairman
i'd just like to respond to a couple of
comments that i've heard
um i visit that place quite often
and it has a step up to get into it
which makes it inaccessible to certain
wheelchair users
so it is not an accessible
area to people with disabilities
sorry counselor langan you're wrong um
okay then we'll go down there we'll have
a look and see if there's a step up that
would stop people rolling in there yeah
i'll meet up with you if you want
tomorrow fella
great see you tomorrow what time um
sorry chairman sorry chairman i'd just
like to say this will be an asset
to promenade park uh we need decent food
outlets we need more than burger and
chips
we need um something to be done about
that
hut because at the end of the day no
matter how many times you do it up
there's always going to be scrotes that
go in there and wee in it
it will fall into disrepair sooner or
later and it will be a constant
source of a money drain on morgan
district council
i think that getting a high quality food
outlet put in there
is the sensible option it will help the
community it will help the promenade
park
and um there are a number of um
lovely uh benches and other places that
people can sit
and eat and i would urge members to
approve this
thank you chief members i think we've
debated this quite a bit now so
i'm sorry chairman if i can just quickly
point um in relation to the first point
that council morris
statement as i said earlier this isn't a
personal permission um there is no
restriction on
what can or can't be sold suggested
through the conditions
so for that point i don't think that
should take any weight in determination
his application
um it's not questioning what the
applicant said in his submission
but planning talks about the lifetime of
the development and
even if the applicant starts off you
know with the most healthiest food if he
decides to vacate and somebody else goes
in
it could be all the foods that mr
morris's your counselor so it's just
listed off as not appropriate it could
be in there so
for that reason i would advise members
don't take that as until consideration
determination is application
okay thank you so much bill
thank you chairman um
[Music]
this is going back to the same issues i
think the applicant actually owns the
van
that apparently is not there is that
under the 28-day rule
as in are they allowed 28 days in the
year
um and if it is illegal that would
obviously have to be shut down
if it if the applicant also owns that
and he's getting this built
and to me it's a no-brainer that if the
um the gentleman's prepared to build
another unit
that would save the council money
is any of that relevant the chairman has
said earlier um
just because the applicant may have um
an ongoing breach of planning control
doesn't mean that we can restrict that
for a condition secondly as i said the
coming and going of a vehicle
doesn't definitely fall under the
definition of
development as set out in section 55 to
town and country planning act
the vehicle
could facilitate a change of use if it
was there if there was permits and tests
etc
but you know we haven't got a definitive
opinion parts report so i wouldn't want
to
give a definitive statement but i have
concerns
if the anecdotal information i have
about the frequency of the movement of
the vehicle
that it would be development and
therefore it wouldn't be a breach of
planning control
and as i explained earlier and as
members know from many times i've said
at committee just because an applicant
is willing
to meet a condition meet a requirement
section 106 doesn't mean that it falls
within the
allowance of the planning system and us
as decision makers
need to make correct decisions based on
the law and guidance in relation to
things like that so
as i said i wouldn't encourage either of
those requires through this permission
thank you chairman
thank you mr lee right we have a
cancer bill sorry i don't speak that
often so
i've got to get him while i can um i'm
not using that as a reason
to um refuse this plan in application
if the applicant's got that because he
hasn't got anywhere else to do it
you can kill two birds with one stone it
will sort out the enforcement
and it will actually give the applicant
a proper base to me it's a win-win
situation
thank you i'll say is that you know as i
said in theory just if planning
permission is given today
it's given permission for the structures
we can't make those assumptions
we can we can assume but in the planning
determination
you can only base it on facts not
assumptions and it needs to be evidence
and
for that reason i strongly advise that
we don't impose that condition because
it fails the tests in planning
yes i think we've debated this cancer
monitors that propose that we accept the
office of recommendation councillor
herders seconded it so
sorry
so first shall we do that first and see
if we have a show of hands
recorded vote yes can we do roll call
yes of course
for the approval for the officer's
recommendation the officer
recommendation side approval
um members i will call your names in
alphabetical order starting with
counselor beale
castle edwards four has a hurd
or casa hewner
or count 11
against
against
councillor stilts against
and castle swain again
thank you members that's seven for the
officer's recommendation approval and
three against you know abstentions thank
you so that's carrick thank you very
much
sorry thank you thank you uh thank you
thank you very much um so that's carried
thank you item nine any other items of
business
there are none and item ten uh thank you
for your contribution this evening i'm
now draw the meeting to close at
8 46 p.m as the meeting is now
closed members are advised not to enter
into any further discussion
and please leave the meeting right the
exit door behind the top table
bearing in mind social decision thank
you very much